i think because this guy is a real
problem for the bail reform movement
now we've all heard about bail reform
and i believe bail can use reform if
someone's
charged with a non-violent crime and
they're being they can't make 500 bail
and that means they won't be able to
work and pay the rent that's a real
problem that needs to be fixed but
that's not where bail reform in the real
world stops it releases violent people
too and those violent people go back to
their community and create havoc the
same havoc they got arrested for the
first time and you might think well why
would anybody want that why would
anybody want havoc in their neighborhood
but havoc chaos is not bad for business
for everybody it's bad if it's your
neighborhood and you live there
but if you're a benjamin crump for
example you make 10 million dollars
every time there's some kind of
zimmerman case a written house case a
ahmad arbory case these are money making
opportunities in the tens of millions of
dollars for you so chaos is good for
certain ways not just money
hold on so political political yeah
you're saying that
there is a a motivation to bring about
bail reform because it results in an
opportunity where a criminal can get
hurt and they can monetize it
chaos is good for some people okay so i
should be clear when i say um people are
leveraging bail reform for political
reasons i would say
bail reform overreach not all bail
reform but bail reform that releases
violent charges
you think that many people advocating
for it i'm not saying every but some
have that in mind they're like this will
create more crime and more opportunity
especially people with considerable
political power like a benjamin crump i
don't mean the individual social worker
who's in favor right right they don't
have any he's a lawyer everything's
monetized right so right the pendulum
has been swinging in favor of loosening
bail requirements more and more and more
until the point they include people
charged with violent crimes and
eventually the pendulum is going to
swing back but when it swings back
that's going to be bad for some people
this case is a perfect example a perfect
warning to the normals in society that
holy cow we all thought that bail reform
was a good thing but it's possible it
goes too far it lets people like this
out on bail well i think bell reform is
a good thing i don't like the bail
system i don't like the idea that we
would say you're presumed innocent but
we're not going to let you out yes you
give us 500 bucks
for violent criminals with a
preponderance of evidence then i'm in
favor of remand as far as i'm concerned
either you're it's remand or you're free
to go until you're you're convicted but
that means
substantially more people should be
remanded and substantially more people
should be released there's also got to
be some limitations like if someone's a
repeat offender and you've got past
convictions okay well now you're going
to be that's almost everybody well if
that's the case sorry but as a practical
matter
you see very few people go through the
criminal just
of the people going through the criminal
justice system on any given day almost
none of them is it their first time but
that
sure but if someone goes in and they've
had a past conviction
and then that they say okay well it's
you know two thousand dollars if you
want to get out i mean you're going to
destroy that person's life
outright before you've proven them
guilty simply on their past well they
could sit in jail for a long time and
there's and there's more there's there's
too many i mean look at kyle kyle ryden
house when he was like he had to sit
there for 87 days and he didn't have
what he said he had no running water he
was not getting good food he was losing
all this weight and he was not guilty so
and he needed two million dollars to get
him out and we can you know we can talk
about the lawyers and stuff but just on
the system alone one one aspect that i
would so so bail obviously has been
around a long time this isn't something
some new system that you know just was
under like the trump era or something
like that you know um and trump actually
was for uh you know criminal justice
reform although he was focused more on
back end than than front end and not
that i'm a supporter of the first step
movement but just you know for clarify
uh to clarify that but when it comes to
these types of situations you know
you know you were talking before about
how
the criminal uh citizens arrest law in
the arberry case was something that had
been written during the civil war in
georgia it was still on the books at the
time that has been updated since
well with these cases as well one thing
that i think really ties all of these
together is the is video right we have
video of waukesha we've tons of video of
it we have video of kenosha we had video
of ahmed arbury right and i think that
in those two cases it was the video that
went to the jury and eventually swung
them so you're thinking they should look
at video as part of setting bail so look
at video that would never happen no look
at it never happen because you have to
understand how this process works in a
nutshell
they're trying to make these decisions
in three minutes
right the magistrate is making a bail
decision in three minutes he's got an
algorithm he uses depending on the
degree of the offense
risk of flight there's a set risk of set
criteria that they use and the state and
the defense are going to go down that
checklist of criteria and it's like a
little algorithm it arrives to make it
part of a probable cause
well a probable cause would be
determined someplace else it's not going
to be determined right there but a judge
a magistrate's not going to take time to
look through
even five minutes of video to try to
come to self-determination of what bail
should be it should be
maybe that's what i'm talking about
in the entire system right yes the idea
i mean we're talking about redesigning
this process is the punishment what they
did to james o'keefe they raid him and
his journals because law enforcement
knows the process is the punishment when
it came to occupy wall street protests
there was a photographer that i was i
was just filming i'm filming and there
was a photographer standing on the
sidewalk minding his own business when
an officer came up and arrested him
they claimed that he was obstructing a
roadway they lied they made it up
they then had a female officer lie under
oath and it wasn't until the national
lawyers guild who i'm not the biggest
fan of used my footage to show that the
police lied he was released did any of
the officers get in trouble they never
do they never they lie all the time on
these criminal complaints they're never
held the issue is if there's someone who
is a regular working class joe and he
gets accused of a somewhat serious
offense but not like not a felony or
anything the judge can be like look i
think we should keep him in jail until
the court and then what 87 days or or 80
days you lose your job you lose your
apartment your car gets towed your
people are wondering where you went your
dog is going hungry and then you get out
destitute so so i i i will i will cite
benjamin franklin all day and night it
is better that 100 guilty persons go
free than one innocent person suffer if
the court cannot justify
reasonably an algorithm in three minutes
is not justification for holding someone
against their will when they're presumed
innocent that being said real quick so
this is where i consider the video that
that being said that's right that being
said everybody should keep and bear arms
and a free society means a society with
risks and if we're going to let out
people and i don't think violent
offenders depending on depending on what
they've committed i think that's
reasonable for a judge to be like you're
accused of triple murder or something
okay sorry which is kyle right now
well not triple but yeah well yeah
double murder plus you know a bunch of
other charges i can understand why they
would be like
look i'm sorry you're being held because
these are very serious and we're worried
about the safety of others there should
still be some scrutiny there but if
we're gonna let people out on bail then
all we need do is look at the
constitution and say the fifth and sixth
amendment benjamin franklin and and
blackstone and the second amendment
sure so
i don't want to come across as someone
who's defending the way the system is i
think it's broken i mean from my
perspective for example i think probable
cause hearings
are worthless the way they operate today
what's supposed to happen is a probable
cause hearing is supposed to be a filter
to keep people from being dragged into a
full-blown trial
unless there's probable cause to believe
they committed the crime so at trial
they're going to have to prove you
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt if they
can't even show 51 percent of the
evidence going into that process they
shouldn't be able to drag you into the
terribly destructive
dangerous risk of a full-blown trial but
probable cause doesn't work that way
today it doesn't work like a 51 degree
threshold before you're brought into
trial it's essentially a zero degree
threshold the prosecutor can say
whatever he wants he can get officers to
swear whatever they want nothing's ever
checked when things are later proven to
not be true it doesn't matter uh they
don't say well the process that got you
into trial was inherently defective so
we're gonna let you out well
what we need is a genuine probable cause
hearing the reason we don't have one i'm
not defending this
this is just the practical way the
system works the reason we don't have
that is because we have so many
criminals going through the system we
could never give everybody a genuine
probable cause hearing the way the
system's designed today
and most of the people going through are
criminals so no one cares that they're
not actually getting a probable cause
hearing no one notices until an innocent
person gets fed into that system and
suffers all the the the
thresher effects of that horribly
destructive system and you see it
affecting an innocent person that way
justice you're just being blind is not
always a good thing here's the example
i'll throw out there and because i mean
justice isn't blind i don't think but
you've got kyle written house was
charged what within 24 hours or maybe 36
hours right if you if you actually go by
the dates right um
alec baldwin
it's still under investigation we're
still reviewing the incident when we
when we know that this took place on a
movie set i'm sure every single minute
of that incident is caught on film
there's no relevant facts in dispute i
mean on the criminal charge of reckless
homicide we know all the facts right not
in dispute uh and we know the law the
law's not ambiguous there so the only
reason they haven't charged them is
because they've decided because they
don't want to charge them that's all
right if it was me or you and they
decided they wanted to charge us we
would have been charged that all day
every day and and correctness
i'm not a new mexico lawyer i mean i
know you're from out west but crisis
management is there a special is there a
special uh rule for actors there's a
special carve out in the uh
in my opinion and it wasn't my opinion
it was someone on the show who mentioned
this we saw what glory already said
right alec baldwin had a crisis
management firm most likely oh yeah and
he was on the phone immediately i
believe that and they seeded the fake
story about a blank and a misfire and
shrapnel because the real story was that
alec baldwin was handed a gun by someone
who wasn't supposed to give it to him
that neither of them had checked the
weapon that it was loaded live and he
chose to for no reason seemingly no
reason to pull the pull the hammer back
aim it and shoot a woman the scene did
not call for that in any way and it
wouldn't matter if it did and this is
what i was saying um i can't remember
who who was here we were talking to this
i said um if you walk up to someone aim
a gun
[ __ ] the hammer pull the trigger what
are they going to call that intentional
homicide yes alec baldwin however got
got in front of the story so what
happens when at the very least it's
reckless homicide so the intent element
is different you must have for example
he may not have genuinely not have known
the gun was loaded that would take away
the intent that's what i'm saying but
the fact that he didn't check that's
still right alex baldwin walked in the
middle of the street and there was some
woman walking down the street oh i see
sure pulled a gun and pointed at her and
just shot her intentional you would
infer intent from that conduct right
alec baldwin wasn't supposed to aim [ __ ]
and fire a gun in that scene
so what's the difference i i know you
know
the pattern it's a set so maybe
something's going on but if the script
supervisor the and the electrician and
other witnesses there said he wasn't
supposed to be given the gun by that
person and then he chose to point it
pull you know with live rounds like
what's the difference the difference is
if you're just in the middle of the
street you're not involved in a movie
set and you walk up to a woman point the
gun pull the trigger blow her brains out
that conduct is conduct because we never
know intent right we can't read inside a
person's mind we're inferring their
intent from their conduct and you can
infer from that conduct they intended to
shoot that woman because there's no
alternative hypothesis consistent with
the conduct there is in the in the
baldwin case because he was on a movie
set so there may be some other reason
why he did this without intending to
kill her but he did kill her there's no
justified reason for her killing her he
could have avoided killing her by taking
the simple step of confirming himself
that the gun did not have around it is a
violation of standard protocols to aim a
weapon guns are inherently dangerous
instruments the standard of care is
strict liability if it goes off when you
pull the trigger and a bullet goes
through somebody that's on you i think
it's murder you don't get to say oops i
think it's gloria allred had the the
great line of it she said you handed
alec baldwin that gun and he decided to
play russian roulette with it i i think
people keep giving him the benefit of
the doubt every
turn it's insane to me he we we we now
know the stories were all lies we know
that he had no reason to aim that gun at
a person because it's a violation of his
decades of security training of firearms
training on movie sets he's been in
movies action movies witnesses have
testified he's got multiple training
that a.d wasn't supposed to give him the
gun he had literally no reason and it
was a violation of safety protocol to
aim it at a person it wasn't part of the
scene and there was a dispute with the
crew over what was going on i mean look
you look at all the stories that all the
news that has come out and it sounds
much more like alec baldwin
has an anger management problem so he
took a gun
angrily pointed at the camera person and
shot and killed her and then freaked out
that makes substantially more sense than
the armorer made a mistake who
accidentally handed it to the aed who
made a mistake who gave it to baldwin
who made a mistake who accidentally
aimed it at her pulled the hammer back
it's a single action revolver and then
shot her with it and then a fake story
gets seated i'm not playing so you're
saying he could have been he could have
been frustrated about something's going
wrong on the set was resulting in some
people were walking
even in that specific moment right so
he's yelling at her saying something and
notice we still to this day have not
seen any video of this we haven't even
seen a sanitized video we haven't seen
anything and there are multiple cameras
filming this obviously so my gut would
say that's an overreach i don't know for
sure but i will say this it's no crazier
than what the written house prosecutor
argued
i think i'd say it's much more
reasonable
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you